السيد.  ki taraf ünal orbital fib hwacha
finicky a fella that a lotta Lotta me
غير عقلاني Kadima يفتقر إلى Nokia لكن
الجنون الساخن ng d de dillhart الرسمي
هنا هو عودة أيقونة إنه
منتج يعرفه الجميع ويحبه ، لقد
اخترناه بالفعل لأن معجبينا
قرروا أن هذا هو الشخص الذي
يريدون رؤيته يعود كثيرًا إذا كنت
بحاجة إلى ليزر qiyan messiah hakuna
matata sternum في رقمي Pacita
LG في الزورق - رواية شهيد LED صغيرة للإنترنت
مارلين إليا عليك القيام بها
ميشا بيكيت أنجيليس على البريد الإلكتروني  ya TB r bar t
+ 1 ym konami تحد من technomage tina
سارة مؤتة wasallam enol McCallum في كانت
همسة إلى Arjuna yeoman dunal Hodja لتكون
لامعة vhari lambdas الحرارية والموساد
فبراير رأى اللورد ساتورن واكوم دولارًا
وفوكا لاكان ميخيا للأسد hwacha
finocchio  بشار الأسد لأن
لديك بعض الأسواق الراقية وبعض
الأسواق منخفضة التكلفة وبعض الأسواق المتوسطة
عندما تفكر في مصر على سبيل المثال
مصر الآن منذ عام مضى شخص ما
يستطيع تحمل التكاليف  هاتف 600 دولار يمكنه
تحمل تكلفة هاتف 300 دولار فقط الآن ، وعندما
تعتقد أننا
نبتكر جهازًا عالي الجودة بأقل من
300 دولار ، فهذا أمر رائع للمستهلكين المصريين
الآن ، الأمر المثير للاهتمام في
الخليج هو أنه ربما يكون المكان الذي
يوجد فيه أكثر  أعلى اتجاه
لامتلاك أجهزة متعددة ،
يستخدم الأشخاص في الواقع جهازين في
نفس الوقت ، لذلك سيكون لديهم
هاتف ذكي ذكي متطور على الطاولة
وشركة الهواتف المميزة موجودة ،
ونعتقد أن 3310 على سبيل المثال هو الخيار
الأمثل المناسب  نوكيا ماهر
هوائي لتيجا مهما كان اجرا Nokia
salata Nokia Hamza one ochio septa lock Abdo
an alpha الذي قاده لديه موهبة
بوهيمية
لك